Let's Understand the Various Categories of
Numbers that Come Under Real Numbers Real
numbers can broadly be classified into
rational numbers and irrational numbers Irrational numbers are
numbers like √2 √3 pa a These
numbers cannot be expressed in a
fraction form like p / ba q  They Are Also
Called Non Terminating Non Rounding Decimal
Numbers And Rational Numbers Are Broadly Classified
Into Two Types Fractions Are In
The Form p ba q Fractions Are Some Times Referred
To As Non Integers They Are Numbers
Like 2/3 And -
1/1 The  The numerator and the denominator have to be
integers p and q cannot be anything
like √2 and pa integers are basically
fractions with denominator as one they are also broadly
divided into two categories
negative integers and the second category is
row and positive integers
Those negative integers are like -3 -1 -19
x 0 and positive integers are called whole
numbers which start off with 0 and go on
to
infinity so whole numbers include all
positive integers along with row and those positive
integers also have a  Special names they are called
natural numbers which include all
positive integers starting from
one so real numbers pretty much include all the
numbers you see all numbers which can be
expressed as p ba q which are rational numbers
and also the ones which cannot be
expressed  S p ba q Called Irrational
Numbers All the Categories Are Given One
Lettered Names Real Numbers Are Called But
Not All Categories Are Named Based on the First
Letter Rational Numbers Are Called q and Irrational
Numbers Are Called p and q and
The Meaning of  The numbers are given the
letter so p is an array of irrational numbers
q is an array of rational numbers the
set of integers is called aa and z
the set of whole numbers is called d and the set
of natural numbers is called
n Let's understand this chart
Diagrammatically let this be an example of
real numbers With real numbers we have rational numbers and irrational numbers
With these rational numbers we have integers And with these
integers we
have whole numbers And with these whole numbers we have
natural numbers So everything seems
to be a rational  The Number Wts Not a Rational
Number The Square Root of Any Negative Number Is
Not Real Something Like the Square Root of My
and the Square Root of
-4 These Numbers Are Not Real
[Music]
Numbers